[Music]
back if you've watched enough csgo no
doubt you've encountered this
three-letter acronym before you've
probably seen it spammed and twitch chat
after a nutty jump shot a crazy flick or
just an insane one tab I'm calling for
the score eSports and today we're
talking about the best vac worthy shots
and csgo Mac stands for valve anti-cheat
it's an automated system brought in to
help weed out those unscrupulous
characters who just can't seem to play
the game fair if you do get hit with a
vac ban it is permanent and it is
non-negotiable now to be clear guys we
are not talking about actual vac ban
players or plays in this video and we're
not accusing any of the pros featured of
cheating we're simply showing you place
so good timing so precise and game sense
so on point and it looks like they could
be now let's get things started with
some unreal back worthy wallbangs
gets the spray shot anyway
oh my god what I need to see where that
even was now that bump can get planted
they have j.w that had to be the one
pixel Oh what is that they they always
believe that they can come back from any
school I just have a few rounds left in
regulation before is that that moment
right oh my goodness
he's using that angle of mine got away
with the two Latinas
Oh Daenerys he will have another crack
at a shot and this time he guns to live
Oh
nifty that he can see in somebody
slammed it the Scout shot
Oh what is happening yeah that's so mean
isn't it
[Music]
oh just over the bolts contrived home
flash out doesn't get the ideal
I should not be possible
from Getty just knowing what Kerrigan
was gonna back to Tokyo coming up for
residents just for us Kenny slow he's
not gonna swim in this I can't even find
the kill does it just find a second oh
how did he get that one that was scrappy
if I've ever seen it why is this shot
right complete and utter destruction
here at the portal to get the bomb down
there because I miss it okay this
nonsense
look look yeah okay time for some reddit
videos here I'm definitely it doesn't
look bad the orphan will get to get a
plot now as well as we're all done even
a through fire and he did go for the
feed but push this guy recant be
aggressive or that 18 HP bombs looking
at plant and Kyrie gonna try to take
advantage of the time well it's doing so
good position wouldn't be can't read it
like a book what is that craziness is
actually the double spam coming in from
nothing house that's the kind of nuts
that's happened that's really rare it
incredible actually yeah
yeah of course yeah that was from
speaking on through the top of the room
if things couldn't go from bad to worse
no you can't possibly do that twice
though
okay guys some of the mechanically
gifted players in our next section
straight-up look like a box out there
they're racking up hills through smokes
through flashes and hitting flick shots
that make you want to spam vac and chat
[Music]
[Music]
this is the SPO this is a major James
several incidents after this
simple untie the home and if it comes in
without
one bottle his mouth that piece could
come back to bite them they are
censoring though and I'm gonna be mating
off it a double you of course
Lance the first shot and they'll be
fully aware every playing on the fight
and yes going to ever mind oh I think
you've shot existence as well to the
Sharks down s one goes for the second
one fully flash landed goes down and
Wittstock dual is Ricky Karen is gonna
be waiting he co charges in dozens Kiko
some damage early on they're down a 72
HP overall pretty much everybody gonna
give us some damage there as well Hut
shroud finds that what you know just
like it's instinct and then picks up the
second one too and then the pop class is
not effective what
just like
[Music]
being on the receiving end of a jumping
shot or a run boost feels so bad
just ask the victims of our next set of
play much more utility to work with
here he comes once again the first base
is attorneys gonna hit the ground
there's cold looking get right he's
gonna go for the style play does he land
the drop does he land the jump then call
it now does he do it no it's gonna
ignore me this position he's looking to
jump up on the sky and he's gonna do it
there he told what get right Taguig down
defy spin air with the tec-9 it's coming
from CT right now rain he's sore news
for take a 47s they're gonna go for this
is strong enough to make a dent in at
least Oh the run goes through the smoke
it Olaf finds claim and that might be it
that might be the winning hit alright
guys that's it for our collection of
that worthy plays now if you've got a
favorite play that you think deserves a
vacation and we missed it hit me up in
the comment section and I will see you
next week thanks for watching if you
want more great content just like this
be sure to hit the subscribe button
[Music]